very disturbing attack inside of an RTC
bus that was caught on video tonight our
8 news now investigators digging into
why that bus did not stop for several
minutes as an accused murderer
repeatedly stabs his victim now the
video shows the attacker stabbing that
man sitting down minutes later getting
up doing it again all as the bus doors
still remained closed a new investigator
David charn's uncovering details about
the accused murderer's past and why days
earlier he was deemed a low risk to
reoffend hey Brian Denise we do want to
warn you these videos are disturbing to
both see and hear 30 year old Dominique
Lucas pleads for help and tries to get
off the bus but the driver doesn't stop
for nearly five minutes and no one helps
in for several minutes after that as he
lies on the ground with 33 stab wounds
video from inside this RTC bus captures
30 year old Dominique Lucas and the man
accused of killing him sitting just
inches away from each other on Sunday
February 26th
of argument seconds later Cole lunges at
Lucas
police say Cole stabbed Lucas multiple
times he then sits back down Lucas then
asked the bus driver who hit a panic
button for help where blurring Lucas due
to the extent of his injuries
two minutes after the initial Attack
video shows Cole getting back up and
stabbing Lucas several more times the
bus continuing its route before it
finally stops on Paradise near Desert
Inn according to transcripts the driver
told a grand jury he kept the doors
closed for the safety of the victim and
other passengers a juror asking him if
it's procedure to intervene is it
protocol in regard to helping someone
out when they get stabbed or injured for
the driver to help yes physically yes
for the driver to help physically not
that I know of I mean the first priority
is your own safety so I've got to make
sure I'm safe enough to operate that bus
for the other passengers also we're
going to be asking for a preliminary
hearing in about 30 days as the eight
new Zeal investigators reported earlier
this month Kohl's served 23 years in a
Texas prison on an attempted murder
charge documents revealing he shot a
person in October 1994. the week before
Lucas's murder metro police arrested
Cole for allegedly waving a knife at a
family also on an RTC bus the eight news
now investigators obtaining this
pre-trial risk assessment handed to a
judge deeming him a low risk the
document incorrectly includes a
conviction for murder but that
conviction did not affect his risk score
since it happened more than 10 years ago
the judge setting bail at three thousand
dollars bail coal paid three days before
this attack
so you can understand why the victim's
family is asking why it took so long for
the bus to stop a spokesperson for keol
is the company that operates that RTC
bus says that the bus was in the left
lane and that it would have been unsafe
for the victim or other passengers if
the driver had opened the doors that
spokesperson also saying the bus can't
move if the doors are open and they
needed to get over to a safer spot from
our count it took almost four minutes
for the bus to stop and seven minutes
before someone came to Lucas's Aid I'm
David charns 8 News Now
and we can also tell you tonight that a
judge denying bail for Cole right now he
is in jail awaiting his next court
appearance which the court has not yet
scheduled